When I read the right value, it says download and install the latest frequency update.
So if we just got a right from us, it's already been done.
How often should you download and install the latest frequency updates?
I'd say about every three to six months.
You have to put your take your computer off of airplane mode.
Remember, we tell you to leave your computer on airplane mode
and do not run Windows updates.
Do not run any Windows updates. Do not run any computer updates.
The only updates you want to do is write updates.
If you do that in the right program itself.
So there's videos in the right section and in the right frequency course of how to do that.
So make sure you don't run updates for your computer.
Just log down your computer and get a whole bunch of ad garbage that we have deleted up your computer.
So don't do that.
Do you recommend that I turn my machine on at 9 p.m.
So that I can turn off after the program finishes before I go to work?
No, no, I wouldn't say that.
Just you can let it time out. Let's say you get up to leave.
You could just slip the program off.
So you don't have to do anything with the computer. I mean, slip them.
Your right machine itself off.
But you're going to get up and leave.
Just reach over and click the off button on your right machine.
Where can I purchase the periodic acid to clean my.
I am probably any hardware store would have periodic acid.
What is the terminal matrix heater.
And tube and what I need it for any treatment in my breast cancer.
No, the terminal matrix heater is the heater for your, for the ion pro wave water.
You know, that's not anything you need.